[Musique]
j'avais fait ça il faut bien féroce que
tu as un truc vraiment qui te fait hyper
doit vraiment un truc qu'on sait que
tout est en bois yard sait qui tu veux
pas le faire le boulot
non c'est quoi le boulot je vais jaune
oui c'est vrai non non la vérité c'est
un même pas les serpents ou non s'il
allait signer les installer sur un
nombre aussi sourit pas les rapa les
serpents pas les lions pas les
crocodiles d'essorer accueilli sous les
pas des rats je me suis fait mordre par
une sur et que j'étais enfant non oui et
bien des là ce soir c'est vrai il sourit
j'ai peur dit saurez comment le quad est
donc mon coussin à se faufiler dans le
plus
mahmoudi a même la nuit non mais j'ai
trouvé sabena gt1 et toi tu vois tout en
étant quitte à goûter et puis on est en
[Rires]
émoi les sourires de donner de l'argent
toi tu avais pas une dent ou
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai j'avais trouvé chico j'ai
gardé pour moi c'est un euro lacroix va
donner aux banquiers avec le supporter